[Music]
people have always kept a close eye on
the time
first we look to the heavenly bodies and
now we look at digital displays
while our methods of time keeping have
gotten more sophisticated the question
remains what exactly is time
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream and in
this episode of perspectives four
experts share how our concept of time
has changed since newton and how looking
into our past can help define the nature
of our universe
we start now at the beginning of all
time with the big bang
the big bang itself describes that first
initial instant the moment when the
universe first burst into being from an
infinitely dense and hot primordial
point
known as the singularity
at the instant of the universe's birth
this point began to expand
ballooning from impossibly infinitely
small into the beginnings of what we now
know as the entire universe
if you think this is sounding a bit like
science fiction or even poetry that's
understandable
the laws of physics themselves make it
very hard for us to study that initial
beginning point of the universe
however even in the tiniest fractions of
a second after the big bang physics does
allow us to begin describing our new and
evolving universe
what happened in the moments after the
big bang to get us to where we are today
how did the universe get so big
where did the first atoms come from the
first stars the first galaxies
when we talk about the beginning of the
universe
we're trying to understand these
earliest moments and how they affect
what we observe today
so what does all of this have to do with
how the universe ends
where we think the universe came from
and how it got to what we see today
matters a great deal when we try to
project forward to where it's going
those initial moments that drove the
formation and expansion of the universe
will continue to influence the evolution
of the universe and its ultimate end
will it keep expanding forever
if it does will that expansion
eventually rip the universe apart or
cause it to slowly drift apart fading
and cooling into oblivion
or will this expansion slow down stop
and maybe even reverse
will the universe eventually careen back
inward in a reversal of the big bang
ending in a big crunch and a new
singularity
these are exciting and compelling
questions but they're also incredibly
hard to answer
fortunately astronomers today have the
tools we need to develop and test
theories that reach as far back as the
beginning of time and as far forward as
the end of everything
with cutting-edge telescopes astronomers
can measure how the universe is moving
and expanding today
measuring how quickly galaxies are
moving away from us calculating the
hubble constant and testing whether
those data are consistent with the
universe that's getting ready to crunch
back together or tear itself apart
this might seem strange because it isn't
obvious that looking at the universe
today
would tell us much about its earliest
beginnings
but this is where the speed of light is
on our side
observing very distant galaxies is like
looking back in time
since light emitted millions or billions
of years ago is just now arriving at
earth
studying those galaxies properties and
how they move
helps us to fit the pieces of the
universe that we study into a puzzle
that changes with time
and studying those changes tells us how
the universe has evolved
we can also use that same principle the
speed of light and observations that act
like time machines to peer as far across
the universe and as far back in time as
we possibly can
detecting light from some of the
earliest moments of the universe
the cosmic microwave background is the
faint radio wavelength glow of light
emitted in the earliest epochs of the
universe and the properties of that
background act as fingerprints of things
that happened even earlier in the
universe's beginnings
by combining these observations and
everything we know about the laws of
physics
we can begin to answer questions that
may have once seemed impossible to
address
newton time is absolute god wears the
divine rolex and all of reality is
divided up into absolute time slices
that is three-dimensional spaces
arranged in an absolute order think of a
film
not the movie you watch but the film
itself on the reel that would go through
the projector
it was a long strip comprised of
individual frames each frame is the
entirety of space and the order of the
frames is the entirety of time for the
movie
film space is absolute because for each
thing we can say exactly how far
something is over and up from the bottom
left-hand corner of the frame in which
it appears
and time is absolute because we can say
exactly how many frames into the movie
it is
space and time are both absolute and
independent
einstein knew this concept of space was
wrong his hero a.j lawrence had
described the way lengths contract for
moving observers
but no one understood why this happened
indeed pretty much everyone including
lawrence himself thought it was a quirk
of math it didn't really happen
but einstein took the math seriously
the transformation equation said it did
so that's what the physics tells us
about the world
but why
he took a long walk in the mountains
with a friend thinking about this
question
he took the train back home to baron
glancing over his shoulder at the clock
on the train station as he walked away
from it
it hit him
the clock does not show what time it is
the clock shows what time it was
to read the clock light bounces off the
clock and travels to your eye
but he was walking away from the clock
the light would not only have to reach
him it would have to catch up with him
to do it if an observer moves away from
the clock the light would arrive
slightly later the faster he went the
more it would have to do to catch up to
him so the faster he walked away from
the clock the slower the clock would
appear to move
remember that einstein at this point was
under the spell of ernst mach's
positivism
what is real is what's observable what
we measure
time is what the clock tells us it is
so if the clock is moving slower for
moving observers then time itself slows
when observers move
what lawrence had done for length also
needed to be done for duration
this was the key to the special theory
of relativity
this effect is called time dilation
time passes at different rates for
different observers moving at different
speeds
it was most colorfully illustrated by
einstein's friend the french physicist
paul langevan with his famous twins
paradox
suppose we have two twins who are both
20 years old one stays on earth while
the other becomes an
astronaut the astronaut travels very
fast for the duration of the mission
returning to earth 20 earth years later
the twin who was left on earth will be
20 years older that is 40 years old the
twin stepping out of the rocket will
only be 37 years old
the astronaut twin doesn't just look
younger but using a clock in a calendar
would have only experienced 17 years in
the same time the earthbound twin
experienced 20.
the passing of time is a relative
measure
einstein understood this
but he did not however fully understand
the philosophically radical nature of
the insight after he published it the
paper was read by a mathematician turned
physicist named herremon minkowski who
did understand exactly how radical it
was
minkowski recast the theory and
delivered a famous talk on it called
space and time in 1909 where he explains
to einstein and the world the true
conceptual meaning of einstein's theory
which is that no longer can space and
time be thought of as independent
elements as newton conceived rather
they had to be thought of as united into
a single four-dimensional space-time
minkowski had been one of einstein's
teachers and was a better mathematician
than einstein
what he realized was that einstein had
unified space and time into what we now
call space-time
essentially space and time are now known
to be the same thing
further what he realized was that
einstein's transformation equations were
just rotations in space-time
but what it means to do a rotation in
space-time is tough to get your head
around so let's use a familiar analogy
of a two-dimensional vector from
introductory algebra
start out drawing an x and y axis and a
vector of some fixed length
now let's spin that vector however we
want it can point along the x-axis with
nothing along the y-axis or it could go
the other way pointing along the y-axis
and not the x or it could point
somewhere between the two pointing a
little bit in the x direction and a
little bit in the y direction
no matter what direction the vector
points the length is always the same
so that's one conclusion the length of
the vector doesn't care about x and y
individually and equivalently you could
keep the vector stationary and rotate
the axes the projections of the vector
on the x and y axes change even though
the vector doesn't that is at the core
of minkowski's insight
in relativity the mathematics are pretty
similar now instead of x and y being the
horizontal and vertical axes just
imagine that the horizontal axis is
space and the vertical axis is time
so let's think about a person who is
stationary in space
they only experience translations
through time and none through space so
their space-time vector is pointing
upwards along the time axis
on the other hand we saw that a person
moving faster and faster compared to you
experienced times that were shorter and
shorter
and when you get to the speed of light
the time experienced by that person
eventually goes to zero
so at the speed of light there is only
moving through space and no movement
through time
that means that the space-time vector
becomes horizontal
the only changes to experience are in
space while there's no changes in time
and of course if a person is moving at a
velocity through space less than the
speed of light they're experiencing both
changes in space and time
the important point is that a person's
space-time vector that is the combined
experience of both space and time is
unchanged one person might experience
more space and less time while another
might experience more time and less
space but the combination the length of
the space-time vector is something
everyone agrees on
and this has absolutely huge
consequences
it means that a person's velocity
through space-time is constant and
further their speed is the speed of
light
a stationary person is moving through
time at the speed of light well a person
moving a hundred percent through space
and not at all through time is moving at
the speed of light through space
and that is a deep and fundamental and
completely satisfying answer for the
question of why can't you go faster than
the speed of light it's because
everything is always going at that one
single speed and it also shows in the
most intimate of ways how space and time
are one and the same and how you
experience the two is just a matter of
perspective but moving backward through
time is another thing altogether
and it's with backward time travel that
serious logical problems start to appear
the most famous illustration of these
kinds of problems is known as the
grandfather paradox let me describe it
to you
imagine that i follow a closed timeline
curve to a point in the past
at this point i encounter and then kill
my own grandfather while he's still a
child
as a consequence of these actions my
grandfather never grows up he never
meets my grandmother and he never has
any children or grandchildren
this means i'm never born
and therefore i never exist and that
means i never travel backwards through
time
to kill my grandfather
so since he was never killed my
grandfather survives to meet my
grandmother and they do have children
and grandchildren together so once again
i do exist and then of course i do
travel through time to kill my
grandfather and you can see the problem
backwards time travel makes it
impossible for there to be a
self-consistent timeline
the grandfather paradox has been a
staple of science fiction since the
1930s
but in addition to producing some very
entertaining storytelling it also serves
to illustrate the logical hazards that
can come with unrestricted time travel
any system in which it's possible to
change the past suffers from these kinds
of problems
and that means that any system
containing closed time-like curves
seems to seem sure to lead to
paradoxical nonsense
you should also keep in mind that this
conclusion doesn't only apply to people
or other living things that might travel
through time
an electron for example might travel
through a closed time-like curve only to
prevent it from ever coming into
existence
on fairly general grounds the existence
of closed time-like curves seems to
break the very logical self-consistency
of the universe
when godel pointed out that closed
timelike curves could exist even in a
hypothetical universe this gave us a
deep and good reason to worry about the
self-consistency of general relativity
itself
even though we don't actually live in a
universe like the one described by
global solution it's not clear that our
universe is entirely safe from the kinds
of logical inconsistencies that could be
associated with the existence of closed
time-like curves
some of these potential problems
regarding time were explored further in
later years and especially in the 1960s
when interest in general relativity is
growing among scientists
for example solutions to the field
equations were found during this period
of time describe not only stationary
black holes but also black holes that
are rotating or spinning
to the surprise of many these solutions
appear to show that the space and time
immediately surrounding a rotating black
hole can also contain closed time-like
curves
like in goethe's universe the existence
of rotating black holes
seems at least at first glance to be
logically problematic for general
relativity and for time itself
over the past several decades a number
of other solutions containing closed
time-like curves have been found
among the most famous are those that
feature what are known as wormholes
a wormhole is something like a portal a
portal that connects two points in space
to each other
by traveling through a wormhole one
could in principle travel directly from
one place to another
it might not seem obvious but it turns
out that in order for something like a
wormhole to be able to instantly
transport something across space it must
also be able to function as a time
machine
in fact anything that is capable of
moving from one place to another at a
speed faster than the speed of light
must also allow one to travel backward
in time
so the existence of wormholes or if
anything else that enables one to travel
faster than light
also implies the existence of closed
time-like curves
in recent decades different physicists
have expressed a wide range of views
about the issues involved with closed
time like curves and time travel some
work has been done during this time
which seems to show that some of the
logical paradoxes associated with time
travel can be avoided or circumvented
and other work has shown that some of
the most problematic kinds of closed
timeline curves seem unlikely to really
exist
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below
you can watch them all on one dream and
don't forget to subscribe to this
youtube channel for new episodes of
perspectives and you can watch previous
ones here